Joe Biden really stepped that I stepped
in at this time the first lady floated
the idea of inviting the winner and
loser of the Women's National
Championship Game to the White House
watch
we'll have the Champions come to
um to the White House we always do so
you know we'll have LSU come but you
know what I'm going to tell Joe I think
Iowa should come too that's good
sportsmanship really the first ladies
team tried to walk that back uh saying
she only intended to appoint the
historic uh game uh and all women
athletes in particular but the damage
has been done Beau Dallas used Champion
Angel Reese and I was Caitlyn Clark are
not happy with how it played out
I don't think runner-ups usually go to
the White House maybe I could go to the
White House on different terms though
um but you know I think you know that's
for LSU you can't go back on certain
things that you you say I mean you felt
like they should have came because of
sportsmanship right they can have that
Spotlight we'll go to the Obamas let me
see Michelle
yeah and he is in Washington Harold how
do you feel about how this is playing
out Caitlin Collins a white outstanding
athlete Angel Reese uh the MVP of the
game and got the LSU Tigers win it how
do you feel like this is playing out
some people are seeing race in this
um I don't I see a comment by the first
lady uh I think was well intended but it
was wrong uh winners go to the White
House to be celebrated uh and it should
stay that way I think these two young
women are handling it I think
appropriately I think Caitlin Clark who
was I thought the outstanding player of
the tournament of the Iowa player uh but
LSU just dominated that final game there
and Angel Reese who got more double
doubles anybody this year
um if I were the president he should
come out to look we're going to have LSU
yes we want them we welcome them uh and
understand we congratulate both teams
but this is we there's a tradition here
we accept we bring the winners to the
White House and that's what should he
rebuke the first lady Jesse the prison
divorce you would right away she is
costing him this next election first she
calls Hispanics tacos and then she picks
the white team to come after they lost
to the black Team all the black women
hate her now this lady is killing Joe
Biden I think the house oversight
committee also needs to get involved
major Scandal Brewing I don't know how
they can get themselves out of this
thing James Comer put his airpods back
in he's gonna get her on uh 9.9 million
viewers this is a great day for college
for women's sports incredible athletes
and I I do hope that LSU decides to go
to the White House and I believe that
Caitlin Collins has this amazing excuse
me Caitlyn Clark Caitlin Collins works
at CNN Caitlin Clark the athlete uh I
think she will go to the White House one
day she's got incredible instincts and
Leadership skills whether she goes as an
athlete or in the future I think she's
pretty great judge I love the fact that
we're talking about women's sports I do
too controversy good but it doesn't
matter I love that we're talking about
it and you know what I'm talking about
I'm talking about women's sports I do
yeah
I have two College athletes in my uh
family women uh women in my family
playing college soccer so I've always
loved it right Jesse me too I was a test
and hold my hand hopefully hopefully the
women's college basketball gets a bigger
contract after this big viewership they
had in this this final game
I apologize for the man that just cut
you off judge um
now the final thought that I have is
that 10 million people
a lot of them were men a half I'm sure
um indicate that you know women's sports
is worth watching it's it's valuable
these women are superstars and you know
what I have in terms of this whole idea
of uh Joe Biden inviting the runner-up
team so to speak to me that's all about
their agenda it's all about Equity
everybody's a winner in Joe Biden you're
nodding no I just I I really can't stand
everyone gets a trophy culture and I
must I'm against kindergarten graduation
fifth grade graduation eighth grade
graduation ninth grade graduation like I
think there should be one graduation for
high school and one great graduation for
college and that's it but I don't have
children so but I shouldn't even be why
am I weighing it
nobody wants to hear from would you like
an invitation to the White House as well
with the LSU team well no not really
I've been there
okay gotta go read oh sorry
I don't want to cut you off again all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else